join my day Joe Rogan podcast my night
all day just understandable mean they're
going they spent four billion on the UFC
they're gonna want to run it their way I
get that it's incredible investment I
don't know how to [ __ ] they're going to
make that money back here's your smart
financial guy how the hell they make
that money back oh Jesus campaign yeah
why did you do that he's not likely know
the way I would do it is I would take it
public
oh that I know right you heard it here
first on Joe Joe take it public and a
that they can make fifty percent on the
money in a week I mean a week after they
take it public because the average
investor pays up too much they pay up
high multiples and the difference
between a non liquid investment and a
liquid investment that multiples are
normally 50 to 100 percent higher you
just lost me twelve inning okay if let's
just say they bought it at twenty times
earnings okay okay
for bidding equated to twenty times
earnings right Zane's twenty times per
annual yeah yeah that's correct so they
take it public in the investment public
the Schmucks to buy stocks on the new
york stock exchange will give you forty
times they will yes
huh while they do that then well what's
the problem with taking things well they
lose control it depends on how much of
this how much of the stock are they
going to sell right they're going to
sell ten percent they're certainly not
going to sell 50.1% because then they
lose total control right but then
they're also have to adhere to the SEC
security Exchange Commission there's
rules and they have to have audited
statements every every 90 days and if
there's if it gave you too much money
for expenses and it's down there's a
footnote they're going to come they come
and investigate why'd you get broken at
what you do that
and most people don't want to go public
because of that I went public because I
could see that I was going to make a
thousand times my money I mean or not
even a hundred thousand times my money
so it was a no-brainer that we made a
hundred thousand times your money by
going public well was he actually better
than that
the I J we can't take this part out okay
I grew at sixty seven thousand percent a
year what's that even mean how is that
impossible sixty-seven my total growth
on my original investment was fifty five
million percent
Jesus crushed that's a lot of money and
then there hasn't been Facebook nor
anybody else to anybody even close for
but unfortunately for me because it was
25 years ago I was late at a little base
at my base was only half a million yeah
excuse me 500 million and but now I mean
without even by your base in other words
what I grew the company from 800 bucks
right just 500 million right okay so for
my base my initial base was 8 a cloud of
thousand bucks okay okay
in my exit base was five hundred million
okay five hundred million dollars and of
course I had a lot of shareholders it
wasn't just me
but now the the company grew if you take
800 bucks and you figure out the do a
spreadsheet on the growth per year at
67,000 percent and you do the total
growth it's 55 million percent 55
million percent now if you were you're
an MMA fan and you ma'am give advice to
the people that only do actually what
would you tell them oh yeah would you
would you give them either I'd hire
something like Goldman Sachs uh hire
more than one I take Goldman Sachs and
JP Morgan or somebody like that or
Credit Suisse to look at how to make
their investment liquid liquid because
now it's frozen like a stiff dick I mean
it's not going anyplace so what does
that mean like how do you make it liquid
liquid okay if let's just say we're
going to take this podcast public okay
okay no crazy okay let's get crazy now
let's just say that the right now
you make let's draw out numbers a
million dollars a year off your podcast
and you have no other shareholders okay
okay now you want to take a public and
you want to take a public on one of the
secondary or tertiary exchanges because
this is would be big enough to take on
the new york stock exchange and you want
to sell shares in your baby for a
thousand dollars a share
okay how many shares does one-half well
you as many as you want you want really
yeah so you can make a hundred million
shares a thousand dollars a share yeah
but you you couldn't you couldn't quite
that much value but you could do a
thousand shares at a thousand a thousand
dollars a share okay okay
and so you sell 20 percent off to the
public so 20 percent of those shares are
and I mean you got millions of people to
follow you I mean that would be a slam
dunk I mean it'd be a no-brainer I'm
being no-brainer but then a bunch of
people who tell me to who knows all no
no as long as you guys keep control
about usual you know it would try to get
that power though yeah within word and
but as long as you held or your group
your consortium or you and your your
buddies held more than 50 percent they
can never take control right but it
seems like that's that's where hostile
takeovers correct right Coran yeah
people Gallo yeah is there yeah I'm get
excited myself just thinking about it
yeah so I'll take over yeah that's like
I don't even joke a well meet in the
cage you can put your best guy about put
my best friend then we'll settle that
with just like they do in the old days
instead of the two armies going to war
the best night from this guy and the
best night from this guy right yeah you
know and and you who would you pick to
defend to defend your honor my honor in
the cage I mean if you get it the other
side had a guy who would you pick good
question but we do in weight classes now
know anything goes this is a heavyweight
named Francis in Ghana I think I might
put my money on that guy yeah terrifying
young heavyweight okay yeah okay who's a
dead who cares
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]